[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I can hear you being quiet mom
I am
hope I didn't ice your game man
no one my age says those words in that
order
it's just hard to see my little man not
be my little boy all the time
here
for years I've been taking care of this
little boy
making sure he is loved
that he feels like he belongs wherever
he wants to be
he wants to go on to the world and do
great big things
not bad kid
and what I worry about most
I love you Mars
is they won't look out for you like us
miles
wanna get out of here
you go from here you have to promise to
take
your boy from me
make sure he never forgets where he came
from
[Music]
and
he never doubts that he is loved
and he never lets anyone
tell him that he doesn't belong there
you gotta promise miles
I promise
[Music]
we are supposed to be the good guys we
are
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it's a long story is this the room you
grew up in uh it is but uh my my dorm
room is very adult right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
I missed you too okay so what are you
doing here I mean I
but I'd never see you again
want to get out of here
[Music]
hi
bummer
whoop
is Spider-Man grounded
um
I mean I
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]